all right welcome to a very special
edition of a beginner breakdown I'm your
host my cover this is our seventh year
anniversary and we have a special guest
tonight national master Karanja to your
current reigning US Junior Open champion
today we'll have another bounty Edition
all right it's her run who goes by the
name Ray would beat me he'll get $50
cash and if you lose this knot and if I
win y'all know what I'm gonna get glory
right all right cuz that's what it's all
about so this is a very special game
it's arm again I'm gonna get six minutes
black is going to get four minutes and
Ray gets draws so up the game as a draw
he will also get the Mickey dollars okay
so in this game in this plot move that
clutch move it's an exhibition but
here's the kicker it is a special
opening that we will be playing as
longtime viewers of Maya show no I am
NOT a fan of a certain opening and
without further ado we will get to it I
will make the first three moves okay
poor
I better change
then I'm dining mistake next time okay I
go this way
right
Oh
taking my advice all right
and the room they're gonna hit the head
what's done is done what's done is done
I guess that's something
anyone who didn't have clock
it's pretty good congratulations to an
esse Master Chorale you know national
master they didn't know what to do by
the fried liver yeah it's like what do
you think a 700 a guy rate of thousands
gonna you know alright so you know it's
tough all right so if you're teaching
students don't teach them let's unite
defence tower in that situation Bishop
e7 Bishop c5 are in the slammer each sex
alright but hey he survived though he's
surviving with the Torah alright so good
job right good luck tomorrow